The jogan Experience so tell me more I
want to hear more about this mental
training what's involved with that so
you decided to do this after the balal
fight yeah so the so what you you you
said you made like some decisions in
that fight that you like you never had
made before yeah I feel like I remember
like you're in there and fighting like
being in a fight is the weirdest feeling
ever like sometimes like you're super
present and then sometimes you're not
like I remember just being in that fight
and for with Kelvin for 15 minutes I was
where my feet were I was super present
like I had like I was locked in that
entire time when I fought BW I remember
like I was just thinking about other
and then I'd come back to like like
like the present I'm like what the
are you doing like like I'm in the
middle of a fight I just wasn't what
kind of other I just wasn't present
like I wasn't even like where like I
just wasn't thinking about the fight
like I just didn't want to be there
that's so weird and I didn't and I never
felt like that before so now I started
working with this guy Brian Kane he
worked with GSP after GSP lost to um
Matt Sarah first fight he started
working with him and then I started
working with Brian and it's just all
about just being super present like not
even just in fighting but just in life
like not worrying about what I got to do
later or stupid like that just
being in that moment and just focusing
on that cuz that's all you can control I
was so caught up and thinking about the
future or what like happened the day
before like if I had a bad day of
training like I'd to bother me and it
just came out of the fight but I just
wasn't in the moment and that's like now
like I just try to be in the moment and
everything I'm doing just super present
not thinking too far ahead not thinking
about the past and that's something I
used to get caught up in a lot just not
not being focused on in like I was just
so worried about my next session or my
next this or like thinking about my
fight like things I I can't control like
I can't control that far but all I can
control is what I'm doing in this moment
so how what is that you do so like we
just have like just like drills like say
if um if I'm sparring and if like
something's not going my way just like
little like signals just to like bring
myself back into what I'm doing like if
if I round doesn't go my way like not
getting too caught up on that and just
and just knowing like I have another
round and I can just get back into that
and just having these like signal lights
like he had it's called like red green
red red yellow green so green all
systems go you're having the best
training session of your life yellow
you're starting to get in your head in a
little bit it's not working out like
you're not getting off your shots not
getting enough your takedowns red is
like you're getting pieced up like your
mind's going other places like you don't
want to be there anymore and
when you get in the red you have to have
like like he works with baseball players
say like uh you hit a like you get
you're about to get struck out they got
the batter will step out of the box
they'll take off their gloves and
they'll like they'll like do like
they'll like tap their shoulder
something and it's just like something a
reset and that's exactly that's exactly
what it is so like if I'm having like a
bad session like obviously I'm not going
to like tap my head or something
like that but just like talking to
myself and just just knowing like I'm
all right like you're good like bring it
back like how do you reset like is there
a very specific thing just I just talked
to myself just and like what do you say
to yourself just looking at myself just
um we have like uh our affirmations for
my last fight were um I control what I
can I control what I can control and I
trust my training I'm aggressive and
always moving forward and then we'd have
a funny one to make it not that serious
it was uh I'm confident I'm cocky I'm
Rocky and it would just
make you laugh and in before my fight
with Kelvin I'm in the bathroom
and I'm saying these affirmations and
then I'll laugh at because it's like
it's not that serious but like small
little things like that just to just to
bring it back and just be just be
present and um I think that and then I
started then I started working with
another other guy through um my
management company his name is uh
Brandon Epstein and we would do like
visual like visualize like the fights so
every week we'd meet on the call and
we'd go from visualizing being in the
locker room well even before that the
first like the nervous like the most
nervous I would get before a fight is
like that shower at like 12:00 fight day
like you get a shower and you know the
car is coming to pick you up in like 2
hours so we'd like close our eyes and we
start in the shower i' shower get
changed car would pick you up we're
walking to the locker room we're in the
locker room we're hitting pads we're
warming up getting your hands wrapped
making that walk and then like for 5 10
15 however long I'd be just eyes closed
visualizing how I want the fight to go
bad situations good situations and then
eventually winning the fight and
visualizing talking to you or talking to
DC and I would do these mental reps over
and over and over again whe sitting in
the SAA I would do it sitting in the
cold tub I would do it I would have my
affirmations so like timed up if I was
going in the cold for 3 minutes I knew
how many times I would have to say them
and then my 3 minutes would be up and
that's all in training camp and I would
just do that over and over and over
again and and that was something you had
never done before never done before cuz
um you would never like I would never
think about it and then before you know
it you get there and you're like
like this it feels brand new to you
again again cuz you only fight a couple
times a year if you're lucky but instead
i' seen these things a million times in
my mind already like yeah physically I
wasn't there but mentally like I I'm
already in this locker room I'm already
I've already walked in the cage I
already made the walk like they would
make custom uh music for me that I would
listen with my walk out uh music
kelvin's walk out music crowd noise and
I would listen to it before sparring and
when I'm Shadow Boxing and like
that like and I just like felt so
prepared doing it and I just never did
anything like that before and um yeah I
it's a game changer that's
interesting because they do say that
visualization actually helps skill
learning as much as training like if you
are training but then also visualizing
things and spending as much time you
your training your improvements will be
compounded oh 100% And like I'm blanking
on a million other things we do but like
that's like the big ones like just
visualizing what you want to do and not
just the good the bad too like so I
would think about like if I getting
ready for Kelvin everyone is like I'm
going to get knocked out I'm going to
get this I'm going to get that so I
would visualize getting dropped
and having to get back in or getting
rocked or going for a takedown getting
stuffed and having to recover from that
and go and win the fight because they're
not going to you're not going to it's
not always going to go your way so
visualizing the bad but still making it
out with the good which I didn't do with
balal like he rocked me in that moment
and I was still there instead of just
making that switch and be like you're
good like go back and just getting back
to the fight I just never could get back
does is that partially attributable just
also to getting hit like because
sometimes when guys get hit they get
they're out of it like you've seen many
guys that go back it's the fourth round
and they go they don't know what round
it is no because I was I remember
everything I I wasn't like I was
definitely definitely buzzed me but like
I remember just putting my hand hands up
and I just couldn't throw I'm like punch
and I heard the 10-second clap go off I
thought I was going to get Saved by the
Bell and I was going to make it to the
next round and I never did well it it's
an interesting stoppage because it was
it was one of the rare UFC stoppages
with the guy standing up yeah it's very
rare yeah I never and that's what I'm
saying like I didn't get dropped and I
remember everything I remember hearing
The Clapper my coaches were right behind
me I could hear my coach John screaming
he's good he's good he's good and he
stopped it which good on him but I like
I just couldn't I couldn't do what I
wanted to do it was the weird subjetive
like when a fight gets stopped and when
it doesn't get stopped and the thing
that sucks the most is when a fight is
stopped too late yeah you mean like for
sure you know the Jaylen Turner Bobby
green fight Jesus Christ that was bad
that was so bad you cage side for that
right oh my God I was like stop the
fight what is happening here I think it
was like 20 something unanswered strikes
or something like that that is so hard
to watch yeah it was um so unnecessary
it it was bad but yeah back to like like
the mental performance stuff like it was
just really just all came down to just
me just being focused for 15 minutes cuz
like we you can be doing anything and
just you're driving but you're
looking off like you're not you're not
in the moment you know and that's
something like now I try to like I try
to do and everything I do in my life if
I'm walking my dog I'll leave my phone
at and just try to be present doing the
thing you're doing at the time not
wearing there's so much noise and other
and when I'm fighting like the only
thing I'm thinking about is
fighting